c'est comme si le président avait
atterri dans une zone de guerre entouré
des habitants de mes fils de joe biden
est venu constater l'ampleur des dégâts
et apporter un peu de réconfort à une
communauté en état de choc tout est à
reconstruire ici
la façon dont les gens s'entraident dit
il c'est ce que nous sommes supposés
faire ici il n'ya pas d'état rouge ou
bleu quand une telle chose arrive
au total 74 personnes ont péri au
kentucky dont 8 l usine de chandelle
cent dix personnes il travaillait
toujours lorsque la tornade a frappé
aujourd'hui des employés accusent
l'entreprise de les avoir empêchés de
rentrer chez eux
j'ai dit à mon superviseur vous allez
refuser de nous laisser partir même si
le temps pire dit il il m'a répondu vous
pouvez partir mais vous n'aurez plus
d'emplois une enquête est en cours
pendant qu'on règle des comptes à une
heure de mes fils d' un spectacle encore
plus désolant
ici à dawson springs la tornade a frappé
très fort c'est la ville la plus pauvre
du kentucky et c'est celle qui a été la
plus affligés 80% des maisons ont été
détruites on a l'impression cette ville
a été rayé de la carte
elle-même
ubo il n'y a plus rien ici dit omischl
albi et ils ne vont pas reconstruire
la sirène a retenti cinq fois pour nous
avertir que la tornade arriver dit d'ofi
adamski ses protégés avec son matelas et
menace très au fait de soleil
l'attorney la déplacer ma maison de
quatre mètres dit il est emporté la
maison ma voisine
juste à côté un trou béant la maison
s'est volatilisé le corps de la
résidante a été retrouvée un peu plus
loin
sur le perron une petite fille flora
ballet soigneusement l'entrée même s'il
n'ya plus de résidence la tornade a
emporté sa grand mère avec sa maison
de disque rare de marquer on l'appelait
gros mc et dit elle elle était vraiment
gentille on a appris sa mort samedi dit
elle on a beaucoup pleuré c'était très
triste
[Musique]
flora garde précieux souvenirs d'enfance
qu'aucune tornade ne pourra emporter il
s'est sabordé guerguisse radio canada
dans ce sprint kentucky